[Music]
well now that you're healthy how much
longer can you play do you want to play
uh for me it's always been until the
wheels fall off and i'm gonna keep going
so i can't no more so i can't give you
guys a time estimate or anything like
that but uh
i'm gonna go as long as i can
[Music]
tyron smith been around for a while had
a lot of injuries they are hoping that
he can continue to get it done for the
dallas cowboys they did not use their
first round pick on an offensive lineman
they're trying to hold that together
today's draft the best non-quarterbacks
in the nfc east no trivia today when
pete's the producer we have trivia but
no trivia today no trivia today chris
i'll go ahead and give you the first
pick
okay let's see yeah usually when pete's
the producer too we have all the good
players listed out underneath the draft
too right but i was leaving that one for
you
i was leaving that one you know
you know
sometimes you just get a backup
quarterback and that's just what happens
here so uh is actually
this is actually
this is actually uh
not an easy
necessarily like one slam dunk guy you
can look at
i think to just say
he's the number one player in the
division or anything like that i think
though
realistically and maybe this is a little
on potential but i'm going to pick chase
young to be the first pick of this this
nfc's draft i am you know again first
off i the man the human the specimen
hey the sax i know it was seven and a
half i think it'll be better but he's a
football player too i don't give a damn
about the sacks he makes a lot of fourth
and one stops third in short running
stops coming around the edge making the
tackle against the steelers on the
fourth and goal remember when they were
trying to dive in the end zone i mean
he's got a way
about him as a leader and a talent on
the field and of course we saw some of
the picking up the fumbles and running
for touchdowns to where yeah he might
not
be his pr peak prime best right now but
i'm i'm taking him first
yeah i i was going to take him first
okay well i think he's he's clearly in
my mind uh between potential and reality
and what we saw last year right he can
be he's the guy that i would want out of
any of those four teams other than
quarterbacks and maybe even if we
included quarterbacks i'd at least give
it some thought yeah i'd probably i'd
probably end up taking dak prescott and
running if we included the quarterbacks
uh look i i
deal with you
eight hours a week and i think on
average during those eight weekly hours
you sing the praises of terry mclaren
seven and a half times at least yeah so
how can i not be influenced by that when
it's time to pick take the best players
in the division uh-huh i'll take terry
mccloy in fact i'm surprised you didn't
take terry mclaurin right out of the
gates borderline superstar
hasn't had much to work with by way of
guys getting him the football this year
with fitz magic hopefully not fits
tragic
that will happen yeah and he has the the
breakout here he is superstar terry
mclaurin oh my god season so give me
mcclure i'm i'm not mad at you there you
know you know i'm i'm a fan and yeah i
think he's better than what the stats
say or what people really think he is
the perception whatever because of what
you talked about yeah it hasn't been
great offense he hasn't had great
quarterback play he i'm thinking this
year is the year where
he's gonna be
statistically amazing they're gonna be a
good team and some big moments people
will will realize what a weapon he is
he's one of the fastest in the game and
you can't leave him on the island so uh
good pick by you definitely was gonna be
in in my realm of thinking here for for
my next pick
all right i you know
i did this yesterday i'm gonna do it
again i'm going to the offensive line
i'm going zach martin with the dallas
cowboys he's still like we talked about
with quentin nelson the other day zack
martin he's still one of the best
offensive linemen in football if not the
best guard in football other than his
old teammate and quentin nelson from
notre dame he's just he can do
everything he's still a road grader in
the run game he's awesome that way and
like as a pass protector
he can block the fletcher [ __ ] of the
world and hold up to that power and yet
he could block the aaron donalds of the
world who are really quick and do things
like that too so uh i take zach martin
saying that he's still one of the best
offensive linemen in football
i'm gonna flip it over to the other line
of scrimmage and because i have a
feeling you're gonna take this guy next
if i don't so i better go ahead and do
it now i'll go leonard williams yeah
yeah giants they finally worked out the
contract with him when they've been good
in recent years and they haven't been
good in recent years they haven't won a
playoff game since they won super bowl
46 but it was offensive line defensive
line offensive line defensive line and
williams is that guy who's who's going
to f the play up he's not going to get a
bunch of sacks but he's he's going to
create havoc and disruption
and
and allow the giants to get the football
back in favorable field position and
with that offense they should be able to
capitalize if leonard williams can
continue to play at a high level good
pick by you i was definitely going to
take him next you know again yeah people
they like to rag on him a little bit but
i'd like to sit down with some people
and go let's watch leonard williams last
year and see what you really think about
him after this is over because yeah like
statistics don't always say even though
last year it was pretty good statistical
year but it's like you're talking about
it's the disruption it's the versatility
and all the things he can do on the
defensive line that's his great value he
can really play all four positions at a
pretty high level uh and it's important
with a defense like that that's a new
england patriots type scheme so uh
that's a good one there and i definitely
would have taken him next um
wow all right i'm gonna give i'm gonna
give another skill guy just some love
here i'm gonna go with saquon barkley i
am i don't give a damn that his acl is
you know he might not be totally 100 to
start the year but he hurt that knee
early on in the season last year i would
think that he's going to be close to 100
and
i still think
as i think about it with the ball in his
hands he's still the most dangerous guy
in this division there's at least in my
opinion and uh he's young and i've never
seen some of the runs other than from
barry sanders some of the runs we saw
from saquon barkley in a short period of
time let alone he can go 80 to the house
so i'll take
saquon you know i was thinking about
taking him as well there has been some
equivocation on the status of the knee
and he'll be good to go and will he be
great right out of the gates awkwardness
as it relates to his contract he's got
his three years in but that torn acl oh
you're not going to get your new
contract until you can reestablish
yourself
another reason why you don't make a
running back a top 10 pick unless you
are damn sure he and you don't know what
the durability is going to be at the
next level and look torn acl's happened
i get it but they're more likely to
happen to a running back yeah they are
and they are to a quarterback yeah you
you're taking a roll of the dice that
he's going to stay healthy but if he's
healthy i think that that he could be
one of the one of the best running backs
in football but but that health has got
to be established and maintained in 2021
i am
i i was going to take barclay this round
if you didn't so so now i got to go to
my next one and it feels a little early
to do it but you know what we're five
picks in we don't have an eagle yet and
if there was any player right now that i
would want on the entire eagles roster
on my team quarterbacks included
would be devante smith
i think they are going to be thrilled
with what this guy does i think all that
chatter about he weighs 150 or 160 or
whatever it is
i i don't care
last time we saw him before he jacked up
his finger
in the
college football championship game he
was ripping ohio state two shreds he's
unstoppable and he's that maybe he's
better than desean jackson or
potentially better than deshawn jackson
but uh unproven at the nfl level i think
that uh eagles fans who are very salty
about the way things have gone the last
three years are going to be very happy
about what they have in devonta i'm not
mad at you for that pick i'm not i mean
i got them written down here in fact i
mean full transparency and no disrespect
to the eagles but i only have three
eagles players written down that i
thought were really worthy of this draft
right here and that was lane johnson
fletcher cox and devonte smith
after that it was kind of like yeah
there's some good guys but i don't know
if they're worthy of a you know 10
player draft here we have for the whole
nfc east so i'm with you i'm not mad at
you there either um all right would you
say would you say that the eagles yeah
right now right other than the texans
the eagles have the worst overall roster
in football other than the texans
it's definitely in that discussion i
will say that uh
who else is in it the lions yeah maybe
the lions who've done a lot this off
season i like to what they've got to
reorganize their up front on the
offensive defensive side of the ball
but yeah i think if you look at it it's
probably philadelphia you know
jacksonville's got a lot of unproven
commodities but i think yeah from on a
paper roster i'd probably like their
roster better you're right no i think
you're i think you said it right mike
i'm the more i sit here and look at it
you're right those are the two worst
rosters in football for for my money i'm
not going to disagree with you there
amazing amazing fall yeah amazing super
bowl champs to potentially one of the
worst teams in football depending upon
how the quarterback situation goes but
devante smith may have something to say
about that all right next round i'm
going big daron payne defensive tackle
washington football team not a lot of
people know about him trust me he's one
of the best defensive tackles in
football and trust me they're going to
have to pay him like that really soon
you know that's the one of the dilemmas
for this washington football team is
they got four guys on their defensive
line that are all going to command like
top you know top end market type deals
uh when they're free agents but deron
payne you know just a beast in the
middle stats will never get say it again
but creates mosh pits you know can
create havoc do all those things to me
one of the better interior defensive
alignment in all of football and
definitely on the chris sims all legs
and butt team for sure i mean it's an
impressive set he is down there
um
it's amazing we only have one cowboy
i know four i know i thought maybe you
might go amari cooper over like a
devante smith that was one thing i was
gonna say but
yeah but i feel like i feel like amari
cooper
i know has gone down a little right
i i'd i'd be more inclined to go cd live
yeah you know what i'm going to go see
d-lan i got my popcorn ready he said get
your popcorn ready last week my
popcorn's ready so cd prove me right
i'll go cd lamb yeah okay i
i'm i i thought that too like i sat
there and was like ooh like okay i know
omari cooper's done more and things like
that but you do expect that jump from cd
lamb to be like hey i'm more comfortable
we saw it towards the end of the year
last year he started making more and
more plays and i think he did get more
income more comfortable to where i think
he closes that gap a little this year
between him and justin jefferson who won
the battle to where after this year's
over they were both going to be like man
they're both awesome i don't know which
one i'd take um so i'm i'm not mad at
you there amari cooper is damn good
though
wow
holy cow where do i take him then we'll
take it no do we need to take a break or
can we get this i'm gonna go brandon
sherf i'm gonna go another big guy i've
got another washington guy damn it the
more i sit here and look at this is why
washington's going to win the nfcs i'm
going brandon sherp you know i listen i
take quentin nelson or zach martin as
far as my starting guards for my team
but brandon sheriff's the next guy you
take i think he's he's one of the top
five guards in football and they're
paying them like that obviously so yeah
i'll go with sheriff i think he's pretty
awesome football player
i'm really thinking about taking montez
sweat here yeah uh-huh i i think today
he's maybe the next guy i mean
you could argue
i'm down to him or fletcher cox yeah
i'll go montez sweat what the hell let's
go heavy with the washington football
team let's hype them up they haven't
been hyped up in a long time you're
right give me montez sweat
baby there we go
wtf wft where we go projection yeah
projection yeah that's that's part of it
too it is all right i get it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports